I said to emails with photos of rashes and welts were you able to see though?
Yes I was. Like I said before, it's very difficult to determine the cause of a
rash sometimes. Well yeah, it's easy when you you know you go out and you rub
against poison ivy and you get a rash. So that is a topical dermatitis where
there is a rash because of a topical irritant. But when there is a systemic
irritant that's causing a dermatitis of some kind, it's difficult to find out what
that is because even if you took a sample of the pus of a rash or you took some
sort of microscopic sample from the rash, you're still not going to see
anything. Most I'm in the rash itself because the rash itself is a
histamine inflammatory reaction due to some irritant. Well the irritant is
necessarily present in the rash itself. So it's hard to analyze you know the
cause of that rash sometimes. Anything that could cause inflammation that could
cause a rash. Anything that could be an irritant could cause a rash. So you have
to do some digging into what could be an irritant in that person's case. And
that's not, but always an easy thing to figure out.